SD what is a Trad wife well a Trad wife
is just short for traditional wife and
it is a homemaker and she cooks she
cleans she takes care of the home and
the children if there are any and the
online World gave it the term Trad wife
for short
what motivated you to pursue this
traditional life well I was somewhat
raised traditional my mom was a
traditional wife until my parents got
divorced I think I felt the need to fit
the mold of the world and go get a
degree find a career and I did go to
college for almost two years and then I
dropped out because secretly I always
wanted this lifestyle of course you need
a husband to have this lifestyle so when
I met my now husband
everything just came into place and
that's really
the inspiration behind it is just it was
a dream